Portsberger has been cooking up some new AI features and I want to put that to test.
We're going to see if it can actually help me find a real vulnerability and also exploit it.
Here we can play around with burp AI and see if we can actually exploit this.
I'm going to give it a really simple prompt, nothing too complicated.
Tell me what it leaks.
So what I'm doing here is I'm asking it, can you come up with usernames?
And can you confirm that username shows you PII?
And if it does, because it is not in English, can you tell me what they mean?
Even though it's obvious when we look at it, I want to kind of confirm and see how far this thing can go.
I'm going to push this really quickly.
It is going to start a task for us.
And now it's going to just start creating that prompt and going through our request.
So it looks like right now it's getting a baseline.
It says, I need to understand the baseline request that returns for the given username, jrodriguez75.
It's really good that it's trying jmartinez.
It's now switching over to different last names that sound about this name.
It is also Southern American last names.
If you looked at my previous video, but I made it on this.
I actually mentioned how to use chat GPT to come up with common last names that are very popular in South America.
Testing it and seeing if it works, which is kudos to them for doing this.
Success.
Found the second valid user, jrodriguez.
That returned a 200 status code.
And it does have the H40, which is not the same one as last time, which is great because it's comparing it and saying,
Hey, look, I confirmed that these two jrodriguez are not the same.
One is H50 and the other one is H44.
So when it comes down to looking at the context and looking at the path and everything else, kudos to burp AI.
It did this pretty, really good.
Found another one with C Rodriguez.
That is another username.
That's valid to see where the future of pen testing and automated testing is going, especially leveraging AI.
Really, really cool stuff.
I've enjoyed playing with this a lot.
But now I'm also curious to see what do you guys think?
Are you going to try burp AI?